if there's one thing that we know about
prince philip is that he really does not
like fuss and he made that known when it
came to planning
his funeral as well it won't be a state
funeral instead it will be a royal
ceremonial
funeral which will be a much more
private affair it's going to take place
in george's chapel at windsor castle
it's the same place that harry and megan
got married it's
also a place that's considered a family
chapel rather than a public
gathering space those final details
including when it will take place
we're all being considered at the moment
and i would imagine a lot of that is
down to the fact that many people
who will be attending this funeral
perhaps on diplomatic terms
will still have to quarantine for 10
days when they enter the country
that of course could include prince
harry as well so there are many things
that they need to take into account
before they announce the official date
for harry who is so close to his
grandfather we only recently heard him
talking about the zoom calls they had
together with that james corden
interview does the queen know how to use
a zoom
uh yes both my grandparents this is
crazy
we've zoomed in a few times they've seen
archie running around but my
my grandfather instead of like pressing
leave meeting yes he just goes
it's going to be a very difficult time
for him not only is he
many miles away from his family and the
queen
over here who i'm sure he would want to
be helping comfort
at this difficult time he's also not
able to be
immediately part of what will be going
on over here in the uk
from what i heard the sussex has found
out about prince philip's death at the
same time as everyone else it was sort
of a
unified approach from palace officials
to make sure all royal family members
were told at the same time but now of
course raises the challenge for harry to
see if he can actually get here for the
funeral
no doubt his team will be in close
communication with palace officials
to find out when that is and if there is
going to be enough time for him to
arrive here
and quarantine but i would imagine he's
going to be doing everything he can to
be here to pay respects to his
grandfather
it is extremely likely that harry will
do everything he can to be over here
to celebrate the life of his grandfather
a man that he was incredibly close to
we've heard him talk so warmly
about him on recent occasions and i'm
sure it'll be difficult for him to be
traveling alone of course
megan is heavily pregnant at the moment
that makes it very
uh difficult for her to be traveling and
of course with little arch she at an age
where
an event like this perhaps might not be
appropriate it makes sense that he would
travel alone by himself but those final
details still need to be worked out
megan as we know is heavily pregnant at
the moment she is not far away from the
arrival
of baby number two and so there will be
many conversations that will have to
take place before she could even
consider traveling over here to the uk
on top of that we of course are in the
middle of a pandemic that proves
difficult with restrictions of its own
and so i would imagine that there will
be a very likely scenario with that
harry is over
here representing the entire sussex
family it will be a difficult moment
because i'm sure that megan would want
to be by harry's side for what will be a
very difficult time for him
it'll no doubt be a bittersweet moment
for harry if he's able to attend
the funeral of his grandfather because
of course at st
george's chapel it was the same place
that he got married
to megan but that really highlights the
importance
of the venue so george's chapel is a
royal family chapel
and so many moments have happened there
a moment like this and a family will
of course present its own challenges for
the cambridges and other parents in the
family with children who are very close
to their great grandparents it's always
difficult to break that news
that someone in this case prince philip
has passed away
but there will be very open
conversations happening
with the cambridge family at the moment
and i would imagine the family are all
preparing to head down to london
in the days ahead so they can not only
perhaps have an opportunity
to see the queen but also to really
involve the children
in what what is a very big family moment
everyone will be coming together to
remember
an incredible life